- On this episode, we
talk Snapchat Discover,
disrespect in meetings,
and how to convert on your website.
(hip hop music)
You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is
The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 170
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
I am fired up this Monday morning
because my New York Jets defeated
many other people's New York Giants.
I was at the game.
I was super pumped.
And we stole it late
which is always a nice feeling.
I was already settling
into a devastating week
of anger and upsetness
and instead, it was flipped
as only sports can do at the last second
and I was very happy.
India, did you kind of pay
attention to what was going on?
Were you--
- [India] - Yes, I did.
I don't have a tv but I
had the score up on Google
and I was refreshing
like every five minutes.
I even sent a Snapchat like,
when you don't have tv--
(laughs)
be refreshing Google.
- DRock, you were watching
'cause you obviously were shooting
the DailyVee today and you wanted
to see what kinda the tone--
Staphon, did you give a crap?
- [Staphon] I did.
- You did?
- And, you watched or...
- No, I watched then I saw the highlights.
- Nice, nice.
So, I'm in a good mood.
We also continue
the new concept of having a VaynerMedia--
Did you dress up for this?
- No, I have a holiday party.
- Respect.
(laughs)
Why don't you tell the
Vayner Nation who you are,
how long you been here.
A little bit about yourself.
- [Matt] Cool.
- Yeah, so my name's Matt.
I'm associate account executive.
Been here just under two years.
Two years next month.
- Flies.
- Yeah, love it.
- Going well?
- Yeah.
- Where you from, what
else, what are you into
besides crushing at Vayner?
- So I'm definitely a,
like my Boston teams.
(laughs)
That's okay,
I respect you if you respect me.
- I don't respect you
but let's keep moving.
No, I'm just kidding, I'm kidding.
- Fine.
- Go ahead.
- Yeah so, working on
a whole bunch of teams,
got some PepsiCo life goin' on.
- How's New York life?
- Good, loving it, loving it.
- Enjoy it?
Good, everything's good here?
- Yeah.
- My man, love having you here, man.
- Thanks.
- India?
- Yay.
(chair clacks)
(laughs)
- I think, you know,
we've been outside, it's
been a while since we've been
in our, kind of like our
home field to do our show.
- That's true.
I think we should start the show.
- Okay, well let's
get into
the show.
Go with me here.
- Oooh
(laughs)
It's been so long.
- So long, we're so outta tune.
- [India] We are.
- All right, let's get focused
- [India] From Mariya.
- Mariya.
- [India] Do you think--
- Oh, by the way, before
we get into the show,
I wanna thank everybody, the
enormous amount of feedback
for DailyVee 001 was tremendous.
DRock, we enjoy that right,
we like gathering feedback
and we're taping 002 right now.
Filming 002 and I feel like,
I feel like we got some
tricks up our sleeve, DRock.
And so, I'm excited to see it.
When do you thing it'll be out, tomorrow?
- [DRock] Yep.
- Awesome, can't wait.
All right, India.
Let's do this.
- [India] Let's do it.
- [Voiceover] Mariya asks,
"Do you think too many brands
are on Snapchat Discover?
"Does each added brand
decrease the value for others?"
- I think each added brand does
decrease value for the others
because it's simple supply and demand.
When you got there--
I mean, when there was 18 apps on day one
or 800 or 53 or whatever it
was on day one of the app store
that was good for those apps,
they had more attention.
When there was three channels
on tv back in the day
that was good for those channels.
When it was 13 for quite a while,
it was good for those channels
and then you had cable and there were 36
for a good while and that
was good for those channels
and then we got into DIRECTV and 1000
and then we got the internet.
Of course, everything is
important for supply and demand
when you've got a bigger
percentage of the attention.
Now, so it's not as good for
the apps or the media companies
behind them but it's better for,
potentially better for
the user and Snapchat
and that's why it's happening, right.
If you go on Snapchat
Discover back in the day
and there's all these brands
and you don't give a
rat's ass of any of them
well it's not as valuable to you.
But as it starts bringing kind of
new things to the equation.
New subcultures, niches,
things that you're into,
you'll be excited and so, you know,
I think that for Snapchat and for users,
as long as the channels continue to expand
and bring value to people.
It's like the internet.
The internet's better
than cable television.
Because it gives more people more options
of consuming what they want.
Then when we'll counter-argue that,
well then, there's just a bunch more crap.
There was plenty of crap
when it was 13 channels.
There was crappy--
Snapchat had what, like eight or nine,
six channels when they launched?
Did you love all of them?
- Nope.
- Did you?
- No.
- [Gary] No, I mean,
- So like, this notion that
limitations curate better stuff
is a very arrogant POV from the people
that have vested interest in staying small
'cause they're getting more value.
I like the capitalism.
And the real meritocracy.
It's why I love the internet.
I love that you watch
or listen to this show
because you really like
or I'm bringing you value.
Because there's a shitload of options.
It's not because it's 1957
and I'm one of the three
anchormen that evening.
You know, when there's a
couple of other options.
I love the supply and
demand of the internet,
of the open web, of the
maturity of where we are.
And so, I like that for the end consumer.
I like that everybody that's
watching and listening
right now, has unlimited options
and they can find what brings them value.
To answer the question directly,
yeah, it's not as good
for the media properties
but that doesn't matter
because Snapchat's job
is to make it better for their
users and for themselves.
- [Voiceover] DJ Chapman asks,
"My podcast website gets
a lot of page views
"but they're not translating into listens.
"What can I do to help conversion?"
- Well, I mean, there's a lot of
things you could be doing, DJ.
One, you need to be thinking
about how you get them in there
And two, you need to
think about what happens
when they get there.
A la, let's go old school.
Let's make pretend that
your pods are a restaurant.
Okay, you open a restaurant
and you have thousands of
people coming to your restaurant
but they're not ordering food,
they're just sitting there
and they're not bringing you any value.
There's a couple things to debate.
One, did you bring the right people there?
If your marketing was,
come to this restaurant
and something amazing is gonna happen
that you've never seen before.
We can't tell you, it's a big surprise.
You might win a million dollars.
They all start showing up,
they weren't there to eat your burger.
They weren't there to eat your fries.
They weren't there to eat your salad.
They weren't there to
drink a cup of coffee.
They were there because you made a promise
that when you got into the restaurant,
I'm treating your place
as a diner, by the way,
in my brain.
You know, you didn't deliver that.
They're like cool, pickles and coleslaw
but I came because I thought
that we were gonna get
a million dollars.
There's that or there's another thing.
They came and when they got there,
they walked into the
restaurant and there is no--
There's nobody in the front
to guide them to their seat.
There's not maitre d' or a welcome person.
They walked in and it's
like an empty warehouse.
With weird signs and they're just confused
to where to go sit and where to go eat.
I'm painting you a picture
because there's two fundamental
things that happen when
you have this problem.
This is for all of you.
Either you didn't make the
right promise to get them there
and when they got there,
they were disappointed
or not interested
or it was the wrong reason
and the only thing you
were trying to make happen
was get everybody there.
You didn't think about
the part that mattered
which was get them to order food.
Or when they got there because
they wanted to be there,
they didn't understand how to
execute on the transaction.
So that means your marketing stinks
and you're not telling the
proper story of getting them in.
Or your UI and UX or promise
or landing page optimization
or directions to do once they're
there, or there is an issue
Makes me think about how
is it optimized for mobile.
Maybe moblile's bad.
It also makes me think,
and this is more of the kind of problem,
that the marketing that you're doing
or the PR or whatever you're
doing to get people there,
it's predicated on getting them there,
not to do the action that you want.
Or number three, they're
getting a very quick sample
and they're hearing or
seeing you somewhere else
and they just don't like you.
Like there's always number three which is,
you go to the restaurant, you sat down,
you knew it was gonna be a burger joint.
You got there, there was
somebody that sat you down.
You ordered a burger, you ate the burger
and you're like, "Eh."
Not that good of a burger, India.
Like just fine.
Or more likely, for so many
people that are watching here.
Good burger,
but I'm not gonna go 15 blocks,
I got a burger over here.
Next to me.
There's a burger one block away.
You're not a burger.
(laughs)
But there's a burger here
and I don't wanna go there.
So that's another thing,
that the friction,
convenience is such king, right.
They may have somebody else's
app already downloaded.
Or they already have to
other podcasts downloaded.
And then they just don't
wanna, they don't wanna even
take a second to download another one.
They, as a person, back to contradiction
of the first question, not contradiction,
different look at it is,
they don't want more supply of content.
So like, I've already got
Gary Vee and I've already got
James Altucher, I've already got Ferris
or I've already got School
of Greatness or I already--
Like, I don't need another
one that's the same.
You're not differentiating.
That was a real business lesson.
That was a really good question to answer.
I really hope people watch that thrice.
- [India] Cool.
- [Gary] Cool is right.
- Cool.
From Brittany.
- Spears?
- Yeah, Brittany Spears.
- [Gary] Okay.
- I'm gonna start letting you
pretend it's famous people.
- Okay, good.
- [Voiceover] Brittany asks,
"How do you personally
take charge in a meeting
"when you feel others
are being disrespectful?"
- I guess Brittany's asking for herself
and for everybody who's listening.
For me, I mean,
I just get involve--
(laughs)
I mean, first of all 99% of the time,
the context of the meeting,
I have the leverage.
Either it's my meeting and/or
I have a lot of authority
or street cred to open my mouth.
One more time, how do you
take charge when you think
somebody else is being disrespected?
- [India] When you feel others
are being disrespectful,
meaning, if it's uncomfortable--
- I see this all the time
and I see people struggling with it
especially if they're middle management
or the new kid on the block, or an intern.
But they have the EQ or
the empathy and like,
this is unfortunate.
I would say that there's
only two ways to live life.
To tactfully address things
or to eat and have regrets
that you didn't address it.
What's the name again?
Brittany.
Brittany, I think that
you have choices here.
If I was in a meeting with this crew
and I was being disrespectful to Staphon
and India felt like she
wanted to say something.
What's running through her mind is,
if I call Gary out here,
and first of all, she has
a lot of context on me
so she's probably thinking, oh crap,
Staphon's doing something
wrong that I don't know about
'cause Gary's usually right.
But let's say I was tone deaf
(laughs)
and I didn't have equity with
her and it was her first week.
She's thinking that if
she calls me out and says,
Gary, why are doing--
You're being rude.
She's thinking, oh crap,
that can get me fired.
And then, what does it mean to me?
People are doing practical--
There's always the pressure
of doing the right thing
versus the practical thing.
And then you're always questioning,
are you good enough to know
what the right thing is.
There's all that stuff.
I don't know,
I have had a very successful life.
Forget about career.
On being comfortable of addressing things
in real time, in the room, if it needs to.
My level of thinking of
disrespect is quite high
because I like combativeness
and competitiveness
and I've also always had leverage.
I work for myself.
So, my advice to myself
or how I think about the
world is very different
than the advice I'd
give to a lot of people.
I think you go with the one strike policy.
India should grab me or send me an email
after that meeting and say,
hey, I felt a hair uncomfortable
with the way that you were
treating Staphon in that meeting.
Can we either talk about
it, she'd grab me in person.
She can send an email.
I like in person 'cause
no context is lost.
'Cause if I got that
email from India, I'm like
that's a little prima
donna for a youngster.
(laughs)
She doesn't know all the details.
But if she told it to me,
I'd be able to feel the energy.
That's one lesson I'd like
a lot of you to learn.
Sending a text or sending an email,
where it's an important moment,
you're losing so much context.
The energy, especially if
you go to an EQ person,
the energy is so powerful when
you can create the context
so I highly recommend that.
But I would probably
go with a communication
that wasn't confrontational
in the room with that manager
or that boss the first time.
Behind the scenes,
lightweight, treading water.
And then, A, seeing how they respond.
Because I would respond,
and we've been there and done that, India.
I would respond favorable
which would make you
more comfortable and
safe to talk to me again.
Others will be like,
shut you (blank) mouth.
And that would make
you not as much comfort
and then I would address it
in the room the second time.
If I said, shut your
fuckin' mouth to India
and then she did it again the second time,
couple things would happen.
She'd feel like she was
getting that off her chest.
More importantly, I'd be like,
damn, she really does care about this.
It's just life.
Doing the right thing is
always the right thing.
You just gotta make sure
you're doing the right thing.
Way to many people romantically
wanna fight against the system,
fight against the boss,
fight against the company.
And I've had people in this organization
that have barked up the wrong tree.
Because they've worked in other places
where the person doesn't give a crap
and doesn't turn every stone
and doesn't have a ton of context.
That is something you
need to be careful of.
Do not walk into a buzzsaw
because you do have a manager
or boss that actually knows
what they're talking about.
Now, if you're great at EQ
and the tone and the taste,
roll, let roll.
But this is not a very simple question.
There's a lot of angles, as you could see,
in two quick seconds
that I've given you here,
it's a lot of context building.
Who are you standing up for?
I mean, the amount of
times that people here
have stood up for somebody
who's straight losing,
doing the wrong thing,
but they're homies.
Matt, let's talk to you
because they hear it from this.
- Okay.
- We have a tremendous culture here
where, obviously, I'd like to say that
but how many friends do
you have in this company?
People you actually hang
out with outside of work?
- A solid amount.
- Give me a number.
- 15, 20.
- Great, so first of all,
everybody who at Vayner's
watching this is now wondering,
wait a minute, am I number
21 and what the hell.
- Sorry guys.
- I thought we were friends.
(laughs)
15 to 20, I think anybody who's watching
we would all recognize
and that's a big number.
There's a lot of people watching here
who don't have single friend.
Outside, everybody just--
If you, not if,
when your friend, one of those 15 to 20
complains about Vayner,
it's impossible for you
not to take their side,
they're your friend.
- Exactly.
- I mean, that's an impossible game.
- Absolutely.
- And I assume, I'm asking you now.
Even though you like me
and think I'm a good guy
and it's a good company, good culture.
It's so much easier to have
Janet's back than the company's.
- Sure.
- That right there, is
the issue at hand, right.
You might be standing up for somebody.
Have you ever wanted to
stand up for somebody?
- [Matt] Yeah.
- Have you?
- [Matt] Sometimes yes and sometimes no.
- Right, and so
it's just tough 'cause
you don't know every--
I mean, I know a lot of the
friend pods in this company.
I knew to ask that question
'cause I knew it was a good outcome
because I know what's
going on here, right.
Even people that are a little quiet
or what have you are finding friends.
It's amazing, right.
We got a good thing going.
The danger of that is blind
support to your homies
versus what's going on in the office.
There are people here
who are the greatest human--
I literally want to adopt them.
I literally want to adopt them,
hey come in my family.
I love you that much.
Who are average workers.
That's just real-life shit.
To think if I was their homie,
outside of work and had all the feelings
of the humanity that is
them which is remarkable.
I want to adopt them.
And to think about them complaining
or struggle, why didn't I get promoted,
my boss is not taking care of me,
this and that and the other thing.
It's impossible for the
other 550 people here
intermingled with each other
not to support that person.
They're the best.
But I have the optics of
another thing which is
the black and white.
Not the warm and fuzzy,
the do you have skill.
I'm the greatest guy of all time.
I don't think LeBron wants
me on his basketball team.
I don't have the raw skills
to provide him value for
what he's trying to achieve.
I'm the best.
And if he wants to do business
I'll make him more money
than he can even realize.
Even more than he makes, which
is more than he can realize.
And that's the game.
And so, that's the other
part of the equation.
You gonna step up for the
greatest person of all time, cool.
You just might get caught
because they're actually below average
or not doing a good job.
Or they may actually act differently,
I mean, this is happening here too.
There are people that,
outside of these four walls,
I want to adopt.
But when you watch them, how they act
within a work environment,
they're just okay.
Lot a sweeties.
And then a little snarky and manipulative
and political in the building.
That's just real life.
So know who you're standing up for.
Interesting shit.
- Got really deep.
- Yeah, it got very deep.
That's something we can all learn from.
I've learned that lesson.
Like, I know this guy, he's the greatest.
And like wait a minute,
he sucks in the store.
I saw with my own
friends that work for me.
So, anyway.
- [India] It's intense.
- It is intense.
It's intense because
it's so, this is where
judging where you work
or who you work for is the key.
And understand what
they're good and bad at.
Meaning, you could have a great manager,
top, top, manager.
And they might be strong at X
but they might bad at Y.
And if they're bad at Y,
you need to context that.
There's no blanket statement,
even on the person.
I have a lot of points of view
on your strengths and weaknesses
from a lot of different people.
Way more than you'd ever think.
- [Matt] Oh, I'm sure.
- In a good way, meaning it's
why we're so calculated here
of what we do.
'Cause we don't take the
main boss's point of view
on somebody.
It's 360.
It's contemporaries, it's
friends outside of work.
It's people that never heard of him.
It's people that work for you.
You can't just be like, oh the boss--
If you let that, they're
just manipulate what's
in their best interest.
'Cause they're just human,
it's not their fault.
But I think that's what
makes our place tick
because people have
seen very senior people
not win the battle against
very junior people.
Then that's like whoa,
and that's cool.
I don't know how I got on that tangent.
I know how,
If you wanna step up
for somebody in the room
you better know all the scores.
The conversation.
The skills.
All the people involved.
All of it.
Did she comment on that--
- Hey Gary, Sam Attard here
from Happy Healthy Human.
I'm curious, what's the psychology behind
why people are on Periscope.
I saw your interview with
Marie Forleo recently
where talked about the psychology
of why people are on
Pinterest and Twitter.
So why Periscope?
- [Gary] Great question.
Thanks hun.
- Oh, thanks hun.
You're welcome Samantha.
I like the hun.
(laughs)
I think the psychology on that is,
you know, it's live tv right.
And there's some people
that are good at QVC
or Saturday Night Live.
I always got a lot of kick out of,
as I started meeting famous people,
I heard an ongoing conversation
of the actors and actresses
that would not do Curb Your Enthusiasm
because it was not structured enough.
They were scared of the
improv nature or SNL.
And of course, you know, that spoke to me
because I think I can crush
those things but if you--
If there was cue cards right now,
I can't read or spell or I'd be like,
"And today on the Ask Gary Vee Show."
You know, I'd be weird.
So I'm always fascinated
by people's strengths and weaknesses.
I think Periscope is great
for people that can improv,
just roll, keep it interesting.
And I think people wanna
project themselves.
I think everybody's
fascinated with television
and getting out there.
And so, if you're doing Periscope,
you're somebody who doesn't
fully take themselves seriously
and/or you're very confident
in your improv and your truths.
The reason I'm super into doing DailyVee
and things of that nature is
I'm not scared how it's gonna be edited.
The only reason I'm even
involved in editing is
sensitive information of clients
and stuff of that nature.
But clearly, the bald spot thing,
I'll talk about anything.
I'm willing to go--
It's so crazy, I think I
might lose another 15 pounds
and gain a couple more muscles.
I'm getting close to
just living life naked.
(laughs)
Don't do that, okay.
Terrible reaction.
(laughs)
That's where I'm willing--
You have to understand.
Let's use naked as a metaphor.
Yes, I'll probably not
walk around naked though,
it's crossed my mind.
Living life pretty naked.
And by the way, I'm not naive.
We've all got skeletons.
There's plenty things that I don't share.
You guys all know, I
don't share my family.
There's a lot but boy,
I like pushing myself
further and further
because it is literally
the last battle of a mile.
When you take ownership
of all your flaws and weaknesses,
you've won.
I actually think that's the
Nirvana of the connected world.
Yes, privacy's getting pushed on.
Yes, they'll be negatives.
But boy, there's a lot of positives
with us all putting our
laundry to each other.
We get accepted.
It's no different than
high school to college.
The difference, guys this is so basic.
The difference between
high school and college
and why everybody likes
college, not everybody but
a lot of people like college more is
you've matured into a place
where you can own your shit more
You're sensitive to your
zits and you weird thing.
There's a lot of weird shit
that happens between 14 and 18.
We change a lot.
And we're not ready to calibrate that.
It takes very far and few between people
that can own it all the way.
We're insecure.
Our security is much stronger
in our 20's than it is in our teens
and that's why we like it better.
- [Voiceover] Adam asks,
"I feel like I've lost my hustle.
"Help.What do I do?"
- Adam, anybody who's losing their hustle
has a lot of variables and
there's a lot of variables
in this episode.
This is the variable episode
where there's a lot of context points,
it's not just direct answers today.
Listen, you might not be passionate
about your north star anymore.
I've been going through something.
Let me actually break
some shattering news here.
For the first time in my life,
I've been thinking about
weird things like,
sabbaticals
and building a business school in Haiti
for five years.
And...
(sighs)
I love--
Listen, I'm still all about
buying the New York Jets
and it's the process of that and the game.
But it's amazing for me
to be in tune with myself.
The maturity as you get older.
My kids are six and three
and they're interesting.
They're interesting.
I start projecting, what do
they look like at 13 and 15?
It'd be really to like--
I don't believe in the school
system as much as everybody.
Do I just take them and
go do something rogue?
Just different things, you just evolve.
And you might've just
lost your north star.
The thing that you
thought you were going for
might not be.
It's why I was always happy that
I didn't want a million bucks.
Or didn't want fame.
Or I didn't want a car or a private plane.
All these little things.
It was fun to be like,
I wanna buy the Jets
and what that always meant to me is,
I want the process of buying the Jets.
Which means I get to hustle forever
'cause that's my--
That's who I am.
Maybe you've lost who you are
or what you want or maybe
you've accomplished kind of--
Or maybe you feel it's achievable.
I would be crushed if I thought
what I wanted to achieve
was super achievable.
I mean, it happened to
me in the wine business.
It's happening at Vayner.
As Vayner's becoming a
player in the agency world
and we're not like, ahh.
Now we're like, uhh.
And soon we're gonna be like, ooh.
That's not as fun for me.
I like being the underdog.
I like the climb, you know.
I like that.
So, maybe that's happened.
Maybe you're just tired.
I mean, I think one of the
things that the New York Jets
do for me that nobody understands is
those hours.
Actually, you just caught
something on Daily`Vee, right?
Me talking to Jeff.
That was the first time I talked
business during a Jets game
in 15 years.
I looked at my phone at the wrong time,
it was a very big thing.
I only spent a second on it.
Like, I am escaped and relaxed.
And by the way, I didn't care about it.
That's how excited--
Those three, four hours are escapism.
Maybe you need some vacation time.
Maybe you need to look
at the people around you.
Maybe you need a change.
Maybe you need to break up with
your boyfriend or girlfriend
There's a lot of intense different things
that could be happening.
Or maybe you can take a step back
and really listen to this statement.
Which is, you've lost your
hustle because you've really
are not in tune to why you're doing it.
Right?
You're just not in tune
to why you're doing it.
That you're maturing
and realizing a Ferrari
or fat watch or court-side tickets
or custom Nikes.
I just wanted to show them.
(laughs)
Is not what you're living for.
It's funny, tonight I'm going
to the Charity: Water gala.
I never thought of myself 10 years ago,
somebody who'd be so
involved in non profit,
sitting on the board of
Pencils of Promise, donating.
I was old school, I'm 40, I'm older.
This new narrative of much better people,
that's what I think you guys all are.
I think you're a much better generation.
I grew up thinking, I'll
get rich and when I'm old
I'll be giving out money
and doing that stuff.
So, you just evolve, right?
And so maybe, you like me.
I haven't gone completely--
I don't have enough money.
My kids can give away all
the money, but I can't.
I don't have that luxury yet.
But you wanna do non profit.
Maybe you wanna build schools
for Pencils of Promise
and we'll take you to Laos.
Maybe you've lost your purpose.
So, take a good step back.
Shut down.
Shut down for 24, 48, 72 hours.
Go away.
Go away like this.
This is how I want you to shut down.
Go to Airbnb, this is a
2016 way to shut down.
Go to Airbnb, find a very remote place.
We have to go?
Oh, I'm taping--
I'm just wrapping up the show, sorry.
Go to Airbnb, find a very
remote place that you can get to
at a low cost, like a crappy cabin.
Far away, on a four hour drive
where you can just drive 'cause you can.
Or somebody will drive you there.
Or like hitchhike, I don't give a crap.
Lowest cost, furthest away, seclusion.
And just be with yourself
and start talking to yourself for real.
For like, really talk
to yourself for real.
One of the great things I do with myself,
is I talk to myself for real.
Nobody is a harsher critic
and a bigger fan of themselves than me.
And I think that friction
in both directions...
matters.
Yeah, that was interesting.
- [India] Yeah.
- I've never said that before.
- No one's ever told
people to go take a va--
Like go to like--
- Yeah, because, yeah.
It just hasn't come up.
But I'm into it.
I wanna take a one month vacation.
I really do.
I really really do.
I really--
And you know what else is happening?
I love this time of year.
I love when the rest of
the world doesn't work
because then I don't
feel guilty that I'm not.
And this is a great time of year.
You got Thanksgiving for a week.
Then you have two weeks that
are completely shut down.
And very honestly, nobody loves the hustle
more than me on earth.
I am massively excited
for two weeks from now.
All that family time.
Liz and I going away for
four days, just her and I.
'Cause Ann and Peter
are watching the kids.
Liz's parents, so that is like...
Like, I'm living for that.
Cool, good show.
You brought out the good stuff.
- Oh.
(laughs)
Question of the day.
If I told you to go away for
72 hours and be with yourself
where would you go?
Yeah, where would you go?
And make sure you watch
tomorrow's DailyVee.
I'm excited about this DRock.
I think we're up to something.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Oh, there is one other thing.
I'm gonna be making a wine video,
and adhoc little thing
for Instagram or Facebook
about this wine I made
called, The Competitor.
Perfect name.
It is the 1999 cabernet of the season.
Check it out, I know a lot
of you are buying gifts
and party stuff, I
wanna make sure you guys
know about this.
Put together like a 45
dollar cabernet for 20 bucks,
I'm excited about it.
But you look at it later, just wanna--
I know more people watch this so,
I wanna make sure they know about it.
See ya later.
(hip hop music)